the bismillah al hamdulillah Salam
alaikum peace be with you thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the D
show we have a exciting episode for you
today as always so don't go anywhere
Sheikh Omar sell a mod is with us we're
going to be talking about gratefulness
thankfulness and at the end you're going
to ask yourself am I really being
thankful am I being grateful we'll let
you decide at the end of the show we'll
see you in a little bit don't go
anywhere this is the team the teacher
this is the things the day
the thing you know this is the thing is
betangel this is the angel
welcome to the Dean show and Hum did
Allah praise to the credit heavens and
earth this week on a Dean show we have
my brother and your brother Sheikh Omar
Suleiman how are you great to be at
hamdulillah good watch yourself at home
did it Lambert analyses like Muslims are
always praising god I'm did I not all
the time through good and bad absolutely
but someone might say look may even
through the bad times even when you got
a flat tire and look your wife's giving
you problems and you guys are saying al
hamdulillah or your husband's giving you
probs Bin's giving you problem you know
you having a bad day and you know let's
say you lost all your money and you're
still it's like you see the Muslims
always like those st. at hamdulillah and
that's about being grateful isn't it
absolutely so that's what we want to
talk about today being grateful and
thankful and this is how we can God
willing beyond the way that's pleasing
to the Creator because Shaitaan he was
ungrateful and we don't want to follow
his way is this correct absolutely tell
us a little bit about yourself you're
also an instructor at el Mago to
minister to we don't to go too long into
it people going to go to the Dean Sean
read your bio but you're an absolutely
so I teach with the muggle institute
with mishka University and Islamic
learning foundation company so you've
been teaching a long time since 2008 I
started under my mentor dr. salah haha
sowwy yeah mishka university well got
you motivated to do this um that's a
long story you know but hum did a
laudable i mean i think i had my wake-up
call in high school and afterwards I you
know I did not grow up to a very
religious youth at all but i had my
wake-up call in high school and I you
know hamdullah was motivated to go
overseas to the UAE and to Jordan other
places to study income didn't I had my
the support of my family and was a
wonderful opportunity and hunger Dina so
at what point in your life you mentioned
high school now right and it's about
being grateful at what point did you
realize that I need to there is a
creator what point did you realize that
there is a creator and I need to be
thankful and grateful for all the
blessings my eyesight my hearing you
know my tongue that I can speak with all
these faculties that he's given us when
did you conclude that you know what
Islam is the way of life that is the
truth based on proof and I need to
follow it and be grateful well actually
it's funny because I
I grew up you know I always knew that
there was a god and obviously having
Muslim parents and handle a devout
Muslim parents it was something that was
consistently in the back of my mind but
I think you know obviously growing up
sometimes in a public school I was also
playing basketball though I'm not very
good right now I you know I was so into
basketball I was in too many different
things and I think that I was just
distracted and then once I started
thinking about religion and I stir and I
realized that I needed to draw close to
Allah me and my best friend who was not
Muslim Joshua we decided to become
either Muslim or Christian together so
we were kind of in an agnostic face / I
don't know if you could say that I ever
went through a full atheism phase with
through an agnostic face and I'm did a
laudable I mean we read the entire Bible
I still got that original Bible where I
went through you went through the whole
Bible the whole Bible at hand it in on
the whole Quran and we chose the snom
together so Joshua now is Yusuf in hand
arena and I handed it out was a be a
wonderful change in my life best
decision I ever made it home did it so
way you you were you were Muslim but you
came to a point where it not just
because your parents are Muslim that now
by default you're like someone who's you
have to make that conscious decision
that you made absolutely i mean i think
faith is one of those things obviously
that no one can no one can still in you
you know you you've got to have that
that birth inside of you you've got to
have that in and we as Muslims already
believe you have that inclination to
believe in one God but you've gotta
nurture that inclination to believe in
one God and whenever you start paying
attention I'm did allow lost my notes I
Allah guides you to the truth is the
true something nebulous is it something
hazy where you know what it's it's
confusing mistico some people think like
religion is something that you know it
doesn't have to make sense you just
finally accept it is this the same thing
with Islam well see the beauty of Islam
is that it's an evidence-based religion
evidence-based absolutely a lost planet
ours has Farrell MO and the hula and
Allah know without a doubt that he is
only one God so a lost penetrata
challenges our intellect in fact he
tells us to use our intellect to come to
the conclusion of faith and in essence
for the most part almost everything in
Islam is
Wayne's with you know in a way that
appeals to the intellect however of
course there will be certain situations
where you need to submit yourself and
you need to you know just trust your
faith but but as far as the foundations
of the Dean you definitely a las panna
cotta calls you out to use your
intellect FL at a pillow in the
statement and Quran appears many many
times don't you think so absolutely
that's the beauty of it that once you
nurture your filth while your
inclination towards God it's it's as
clear as nine-day hamdulillah so what
was it about Islam what was it about
this way of life that we know that it's
the same way of life that was sent to
all the messengers of God have a direct
connection a direct dial up with the one
who created you know intermediaries
you're not praying to dead people in the
grave to angels to saints two monkeys to
elephants to the Sun the moon to a
messenger you're praying to the one who
created creation and you're striving
your best to obey Him to be grateful
right so what was it about it what were
some of the evidence is I know you can
you know talk on this for for the whole
show but what are some things for the
viewing audience someone who's like why
should I be thankful you know why should
I have to pray five times a day you know
what was it to give them this firm
conviction that you found you got from
you know investigating Islam what were
some of the proofs and evidences I think
that you know first and foremost again
the issue of using the intellect there
was proof to it there's proof to the
Quran being a revelation of god there's
a proof to the messengership of muhammed
sallalahu ID wassalam and at the same
time you know I I think I firmly had a
belief that there was a god okay but
that I was kind of in that phase where
why would there be an organized religion
and then I thought to myself well why
would God create us without giving us a
religion and a way to get to him it
doesn't make sense that's that's just as
illogical as you know as saying that you
know somehow to lie you you you create
something like a system a very
complicated system or complex system
that's meant to serve you and then you
give it no directions or instructions
whatsoever so I said there must be
instruction and then I found that that
other faiths that claim monotheism
unfortunately are not you mentioned some
examples some reasons why but are not
100% monotheistic there is some there
are some flaws there
I found that Islam was the only
monotheistic faith in the true sense of
the word and I think that any professor
of religion would agree it centers
around monotheism not just monotheism in
our worship but monotheism in the way we
carry ourselves monotheism in every
aspect of our lives and that is the
essence of gratitude that you worship
God the way that he wants you to worship
Him that is that is gratitude that's the
greatest expression of gratitude the app
you know and somehow the Lots it was
just an amazing thing because when I
looked in the Bible I found that even
eres honest and I'm Jesus peace be upon
him was inconsistent you know gratitude
and worship of his Lord falling on his
face and prayer as is mentioned in
Matthew and when I saw all that and I
said you know then then why should I
need to go to anyone else to get to God
you know it's just it's you know compare
having to ask someone else to what says
in the Quran who a couple alaikum
inhabited worried that Allah is closer
to you than your jugular vein he's right
there you can just call upon him in a
loss of Hannah Montana will certainly
answer your call so that was that was
really the most appealing aspect he's a
one-gun he's one God that is most
merciful most gracious most
compassionate and he's also one that's
accessible you can call upon him at any
time so you develop a direct
relationship with God and if your entire
purpose is to center around God then
it's only befitting that your
relationship is only with God and not
with anyone else the car has an
instruction manual the computer has an
instruction manual instruction that the
cellphone has an instruction manual
alright and that makes sense you were
looking and you were like there's got to
be an instruction manual for the human
being you found a crown is that
instruction manual have allowed the poor
on and then the son of the Prophet
slyszalem the fact that you have an
application so you have you know the
beauty of Islam is that not only is our
text our scripture preserved so
flawlessly but the interpretation of the
scripture is preserved so flawlessly
which is the prophet salallahu rds-a x
example the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him as I saw the Aloha may Allah be
pleased with her explain today you know
I explained he was a walking on which is
so if I can't understand
this word I can just go to the prophets
license life and I can I can see even
the Sunnah has been preserved flawlessly
and happen to do that but we got to go
to break wouldn't be back so not to
disparage against anybody or anybody's
religion but we don't have original text
edit feat temporary temper proof like we
have the Quran where it's memorized by
millions all over the globe people have
memorized this book it's a living
miracle absolutely is that a fact not
fiction that is a fact we don't have
there for instance the original Bible we
don't have the original we believe in
the Torah in the injeel and these books
that were given to Moses to Jesus but do
we have those in their original because
you teach a comparative religion class
right you've investigated this right
absolutely not in fact we would find
that there are at this point there are
over four thousand versions of the Bible
and on top of that they're over 36,000
sects of Christianity and largely once
you open that door for in authenticity
and you know fables and traditions and
adaptation to come into the faith and
innovation then unfortunately it becomes
lost even though there might be
sincerity the intellect becomes lost and
so the way to follow and please God
becomes lost also okay we're going to
take a break I'm excited and I'm sure
you're excited we're going to be back
with some more no anywhere would be back
on addy show I'm not afraid to stand
alone its allies by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stay alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if a las bombas I
i am not afraid to stay
you
welcome back to the Dean show on the
Dean show we are talking about serious
topics and this is serious because death
is a reality people are sleeping
hollywood bollywood music entertainment
r-rated movies everything is this
distracting the people people are
laughing fun and games but when the
angel of death comes to take your soul
if you've been sleeping it's going to be
an uncomfortable feeling is that right
or is it not so we want to do as much
good as we can and the best good is
obeying the Creator and doing all the
good days told us to do talk about for a
minute the seriousness of taking def
seriously it's not where obviously we're
not callin to be pessimistic and just
you know they can't live a fruitful life
but a balance like so I tried it like
sometimes get that feeling you know
because that feeling makes everything
else all your problems go away when you
make Jenna when you make the hereafter
big this dunya becomes small so talk to
us that moment when death comes and and
Angel of Death is snatching your soul
out of your body is that is that
something pleasant if you haven't
prepared for it you've been ignoring the
call well here's the idea I mean the
what's more pessimistic than
non-existence and uncertainty so when we
speak of death we don't speak of death
in a way to make people despair in fact
this bearing is is a sin and stop you
should not despair from your Creator you
know it's actually the peak of optimism
thinking about what comes next that
there's something better that you know
what you don't have to be all caught up
trying to get your fair share in life
and if someone wrongs you and then you
can turn the other cheek because you
understand that there is an afterlife
that you can you know you can come to
that that peace of mind and that
tranquility understanding that there is
something more than this because
obviously this world will not satisfy
anybody no one no one has entered into
this world holistically with their
spirits and with their mind body and
soul except that they've been
disappointed so you know how many loud
we have something to look forward to and
the prophet salallahu some he actually
said something very powerful he said
that whoever loves to meet allah allah
loves to meet him and whoever hates to
meet allah allah hates to meet him
so I shuttle the alone have the wife of
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
she said but o Messenger of Allah you
know we all hate death and he said
that's not what I'm talking about he
said verily the believer whenever he's
given the news of the mercy of allah and
his bounties and his blessing then he
loves to meet him and at the same time
whenever the the person who has angered
his lord has given the news of the anger
of his lord and his and his own
wastefulness in his own heedlessness
then he hates to meet God because he
hates to be held accountable so how did
he laugh for us we are we are
consistently looking forward to meeting
our Creator although we are the most we
are the most afraid of possibly falling
into ingratitude and and things of that
sort because we understand the the
bounties and the blessings that he has
bestowed upon us but at the same time we
love to meet him we longed to meet and
it's like when you go to the airport and
you've got you know you've got
departures and arrivals I always notice
this you know yeah you go you go on one
floor and everybody's sad and everyone's
crying and then you go on the other
floor which is arrivals and everyone's
happy and rejoicing we are we're missing
a lot we can't wait to meet him we love
God you know and that's why the scholar
said even when you go to your prayer go
to your prayer with a cut it that is
much stuck with the heart that is
longing for Allah I miss you a lot can't
wait to talk to you I've been missing
you I want to talk to you again you know
so we can't wait to meet him and to see
him in sha Allah to have that blessing
and that bounty so we're looking forward
to it a lot so that's amazing we want to
see our Creator and that is what gives
us motivation there's hope there's light
at the end of the tunnel through all the
hard times through all the good times
you know we not we're not getting
attached to this life because we're
going to have to say bye bye but those
people now and that's part of being
grateful isn't it and that's what we're
going to go on from here I want to give
a live example I know somebody people
know certain people and we can kind of
critique again a person's life and again
this is not to disparage against anybody
but for that person that we love because
Islam says love all mankind and if we
don't share we don't care so we are
sharing so in sha Allah the person can
see that we really care in Allah cares
about you the most so be grateful so you
can be
cessful we know many people are coming
to islam is the fastest growing way of
life in the world some people now
they're coming to islam but now they're
having a very hard time establishing the
prayer the call for the men on friday is
you know the jumma so we know we need to
be a gentle and we need to be
understanding with many of those who are
coming to islam and they're having a
hard time but how can we motivate not
only the new Muslims but many al
hamdulillah they're jumping right into
it establishing the prayer to come into
joumana they're trying to leave all the
things that are displeasing to the
crater you know around people of
knowledge and it's producing good
results their characters getting better
they're leaving off drugs alcohol lying
deceiving cheating Islam calls the good
and it produces good but now others
they're straggling their feet and
they're not taking these things
seriously is that a sign of
ungratefulness on thankfulness well the
challenge of shape on the talents of the
devil in the first place was that o
Allah you will not find the majority of
your servants to be from those who are
grateful from a Shack adine now it's
it's the reason why shape on comes with
that message the devil tries to inspire
in gratitude is because disobedience is
born out of ingratitude and obedience is
born out of gratitude you know think
about your worldly relationships your
relationship with your parents why is it
that we have kids at 18 years old
telling their parents to shut up and go
away and you don't know it's because
they forgot the 18 years and even before
that the nine months in the belly and
even before that the anticipation and
things of that sort in the preparation
they forgot they were ungrateful and
because of that ingratitude they were
able to disobey now for us there's a
great scholar of Islam by the name of
Rahim no item may allah be pleased with
him a man came to me and said you know
what give me permission to send I'm sin
is making me feel guilty so why don't
you just give me give me an excuse to
sin he said okay if you want to sin
against a law if you want to disobey
your Creator then disobey your Creator
in a place where he can't see you and he
said well wait a minute Allah sees me
everywhere so sorry let's try something
else he says well if you want to disobey
Allah at least have the courtesy to
disobey Him in a place that doesn't
belong to him he's
but it all belongs to a lot this is all
his his universe the universe in his
creation in fact the limbs that he's
giving me which I'm trying to disobey
him with you know that's that that in
and of itself that belongs to a lot all
belongs to a laissez okay well at least
if you're going to disobey Allah then
don't eat from his food in his drink in
his sustenance and he said but
everything is provided by Allah right so
those some how to love you really think
about that you know and you really give
that some extra thoughts how can I bring
myself to use that the capacity are the
qualities that Allah has given me you
know whether it's its fame or popularity
or wealth or it's it's you know
intellect or its public speaking how can
I use that against Al off my hands my
eyes my my feet my eat how can I use
that against a lot and so we should be
saying alhamdulillah we should be
thanking Allah for the blessing of being
able to thank Allah because not everyone
can thank Allah right in one great
scholar shahab was hopin her a knee may
allah be pleased with him preserve him
great scholar in Egypt he said if Allah
allows you to die saying alhamdulillah
then you have died in that because you
still owe him al hamdulillah for
allowing you to say it have the love
before you died you still owe him one
subhanAllah because you're able to thank
him that in and of itself is a great
blessing being able to speak and
thinking so what I'm trying to say is
that and and you know that's why
gratitude is the total package the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
said that whoever is not grateful to
people will not be grateful to Allah
grant you know just recognizing the
blessings and the bounties and the
favors that people have done for you and
Allah says in the Quran while in town
doing it that's a lot that's what so
high if you were to count the blessing
in the singular the blessing not niram
the blessing of Allah you would not be
able to do so because from one blessing
every blessing that God has given you
you can extract hundreds and thousands
of blessings think about the blessing of
the hand it's not one blessing what is
all the two what is it that you do with
your hand think about the blessing of
your mother the blessing of your parents
the blessing of your spouse the blessing
of your children the blessing of your
eyes you know I had I had one
I knew a brother that lost his ability
to blink his eyes he had a minor
paralysis he could not blink his eyes
anymore and he realized somehow a lot
just the blessing of being able to blink
keeps your eyes moist yes and so his eye
he was constantly in pain afterwards
because he had to keep on putting eye
drops and that's something do we
actually thank Allah for every time we
link we don't even think about it are we
actually able to thank Allah subhanAllah
de for the thousands of processes that
are taking place in our body at this
moment right now we're not able to so
all we do is we submit ourselves in
humility and say oh Allah I can't thank
you enough but here's my best shot and
I'll show me mercy this is the best I'm
trying but at the end of the day I know
I'm not going to be able to repay you so
please just show me mercy subhanAllah
say alhamdulillah thank God thank God
for everything that we have only got the
one guy that Jesus called the people to
worship that Mohammed call the people to
worship all the messengers call people
to not worship themselves but they call
people to worship the One God and we'll
be right back with more here in the Dean
show I'm not stand alone if allies by my
side I am Not Afraid
I am not afraid to stand alone if Eliza
i am not afraid to stand
iserlohn d oz I
al are so low ya know so clear sir I
would go to my room lock the door
prostrate and cry thank God you know me
better than myself show me the right way
and I will not look that I will leave
everything behind a lot of that crater
and it creates everything kids
intelligent to shoot off her eyes
muhammad peace be upon muhammad is one
of the last messenger since we got back
here on the DS show thank you for tuning
in i said i know a person who came to
islam and he used to believe that Jesus
died for his sins and we got to
reasoning with him saying that look
nobody is going to give you a free ride
you're accountable for yourself jesus
never taught this he never claimed he
was God he never said he's dying for the
sins of the world this is something of a
concoction that human beings have come
up with there's only one God and you
repent to him directly alone we gave him
the evidences to prove and through some
dialogue through some you know showing
the Muslim character and giving him the
evidence he accepted Islam and it seemed
like at that point he was down and out
he almost didn't have a dime to his name
and he needed a job and we know this
brother who actually gave him a job
helped him on his feet and this is the
Muslim character to help to help because
this is what brings us reward from the
crater so we know that this brother was
coming along he was also in a marriage
that didn't work out he didn't have
access to his son this was eating him up
very intelligent man and he was striving
to want to make his own business so he
didn't have it he never died he was
sleeping in his car you know so now he
started implementing Islam and he
started to be grateful I'm telling you
this person he successfully got his own
business started making money Allah the
creator and I need you know how
sometimes when you have a split in a
relationship and it's a bad split he
couldn't get close to his son at all it
was driving him nuts a loss soften the
woman's heart and he kept complaining
about this that I want to see
my son is even he was able to now to
this day he has a relationship with his
son he was going to the foreign of
mustard he was making the the Friday
hood but praying praying you know but
now it seemed like he got the position
okay he got his own business he got all
these things it seems like now what
we're hearing about him he's not even
praying he gets exasperated he gets
exasperated irritated when he starts
hearing the call and it seems like he
drifted off now that he has these things
when he was down and out sleeping in the
car didn't have a dime to his name he
was around brothers he had a family but
now it seems like he's being less
grateful and thankful so we want to kind
of talk about in the brief few minutes
that we have what is going on and you
can see he's not happy before it seemed
like you know he was just full of he was
more gregarious he was you know feeling
better he said man when he took his sure
how there was the best day in his life
now when you come around him sometimes
he's like I said he gets irritated mood
swings angry is this a cause of that
talk to us well I'll just summarize it
with one Iron Man 1 verse no quran allah
says no quran allah in arabic amla in
jakarta ma Zedong McCune well in
carrollton inaudible a shoddy Allah says
that your if your Lord announced
proclaimed if you are grateful I will
increase you and if you are ungrateful
then know that my punishment is severe
now the interesting subtlety in this
ayah gratitude brings about increase
increase doesn't necessarily bring about
gratitude you see whenever you're a
grateful person your situation could not
be the best of situations but you see
more you see you always see the glass
half full not half empty and so you're
consistently and praised regardless of
your situations where I sometimes as the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
Allah might give you a you know if the
son of Adam is given a valley of gold
then he'll want another one and then if
he has to heal want three you know if
you're if you're after increase some
people think once i have then i'll
become grateful but gratitude brings
about increase and that's when the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him used
to make the door
what was saturday feed daddy and grant
me expansion in my home he wasn't making
dua to Allah to to transform his house
into a mansion his house was so small so
the Lhari salaams about 9 by 4 I mean
it's a very small house so small his
house was so small that whenever he
would pray he would have to tap the what
the legs of his wife I said to move her
like so that he could make so dude so
was he asking a lot for a bigger house
he could have asked anybody to you know
he was the prophet of allah so I some
they would have given it to him he was
saying allow me to feel like my home is
more spacious meaning what grant me
blessing and what I've been given and so
that's once you have Boudica and
blessing and what you're given then you
feel the increase then you feel the
increase otherwise sometimes increase
can be a punishment right and that's a
law says in the Quran do not be amazed
by their wealth the wealth that they've
amassed and the children so and so forth
you read law in your ID Bobby Allah
wants to punish them with that you know
it's a punishment whenever you chase
this world and the things that you've
that you've toiled for turn their backs
on you your children for example and you
didn't instill in them Islam you stayed
away from being grateful and you did not
teach them Islam properly and you were
after you know making sure that they had
a BMW and making sure they always had
everything they were always pampered and
things of that sort and then they grow
up to tell you you know get out of my
life I don't even know you it's a
punishment your wealth when you spent
your youth when you spent your health
when you spent all of that toiling after
its and then you realize at the end of
the day okay my bank account is fuller
but I'm not any happier that's a
punishment so what I would say to that
brother and two others in that situation
understand that Allah will call you out
on your unfulfilled promises you know
and that's the thing we all make
promises whenever we're in states of
vulnerability and I'm sure he did
absolutely and a lot will call you out
on that you know it's it's it's a lot
help you know the Prophet slice that I
mentioned to us the story of a leper a
blind man and a bald man you know who
who were all poor and the lost panna
cotta sent the angel to all three of
them and the angel ask them what they
wanted and just to paraphrase the hadith
I'm really pair
raising the hadith each one of them
wants it for their sickness to be cured
and wanted a valley of some sort of
animal and Allah gave it to all of them
two of them became ungrateful and
whenever they saw a certain person in
the same situation that they were so the
leper saw leprous all and so forth
whatever they saw a person in the exact
same situation as them they acted like
they've never been in that situation
they were arrogant they were and it was
actually an angel that was posing as a
man in the situation that they used to
be in to show them hey look this is what
you used to be don't forget what you
used to be because in essence when we
become ungrateful it's because we forgot
who we were and that's why a loss of
hanataro says putita in San Matt Farah
may men be destroyed how ungrateful is
he min I ishe in halacha from what was
he created a lot reminds you what you
were created from you forgot where you
came from you forgot your moment of
vulnerability you know allah says the
masa vida es salaam you know first you
were created from a dirty drop of fluid
then allah made the path easy for you
and even above the alondra said it's not
just Islam the path of it's not easy a
lot literally made them the path easy
for you coming out of your mother's
stomach company children die in labor
how many mothers die in labor you know
how miraculous is it when you study
medicine that a child can even make it
out there so a lot of remind you of your
origin so when you go back and you
remember your state of vulnerability
then you say wow Allah gave me all of
this and look at what I'm doing look at
a hungry pain you know I'm trying
repaying a loss pads are only with
ingratitude in disobedience so we asked
a lot to protect this we all fall in
that we all fall in that Allah protect
us and help us to be grateful so we get
to Jenna paradise I mean people can look
you up at El maghrib and mishkat and
Islamic learning foundation and Islamic
learning foundation what it is a
particular website ilf houston org
Mishka University calm and al-mahmoud up
institute org take his class take his
class we can benefit from your knowledge
may Allah the great increase you thank
you for being with us well thank you
very much and thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Dean show we got
to benefit from another one of our
guests God willing you'll take this
information and you will implement it
and be grateful and thankful before
death overtakes you and
you don't want to die in the state that
you've forgotten about the crater so now
he's made you forget about yourself you
know where you came from from a dirty
fluid and look at you now God Almighty
has answered your prayers and has given
you so much and what does he expect from
us to be good to do good so we could be
the best in society and you have to
follow the blueprint otherwise you can't
do it on your own you'd be following
your lusts and desires and you'll end up
destroying yourself so don't destroy
yourself be the best that you can be and
bring yourself to the full potential but
you've got to follow the game plan the
game plan is what the crater has sent
down throughout time and we have it
preserved in the Quran last and final
revelation sent to mankind and the
authentic sayings traditions of the last
the fundamental problem Hamid peace be
upon him it's there and if you like to
pick it up give us a call at one eight
hundred 662 Islam to learn more we'll
see you next time inshallah God willing
don't forget to pick up the new dunya to
Dean also a Teddy DVD com we'll see you
next time peace be unto you